[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people are brilliant guests this week is
a journalist and broadcaster Mike Graham
welcome to trigonometry thank you very
much thanks our advice would be very
nice B's you little place you go I don't
know if I'm allowed to say where it is
in case you have sort of you know people
that might come here and do you home
yeah but it's a very nice part in North
London I took a little time to find it
but it's an amazing part of the world
this I really like it I actually did
used to do a show with a guy called Mike
Perry called the two Mike's and we
actually started a comedy career in hell
and chickens was not a million miles
away from you and it went from from bad
to worse basically and now don't work
them anymore
I mean you've described me as a
brilliant and fascinating already so I
hope I can be there I don't know if I
can be but for anyone who doesn't know
who I am my dearest Cheryl radio every
day Monday through Friday 10:00 to 1:00
up against James O'Brien who's not one
of my favorite people I knew him when he
was a sort of an apprentice journalist
during a period of his life when he used
to say and he's now he regularly says
now in his book that he was a failed
journalist mutually entirely correct
showbiz sort of runner turn up at
parties and try and get quotes from
people and he didn't do very well now he
claims to be this kind of great thinker
and I'm not quite sure how he managed to
make that leap but my mission in life is
to get him off the air base he's got
much bigger audience than me because
he's working for a station that's been
going you know for a lot longer mmhmm
yeah so before I got he's a radio there
was a newspaper guy was in Fleet Street
Co rocky it's 25 years really when it
was when it was hot when it was great
when it was amazing when he could
basically go over murder and obviously
we couldn't do it now some of the stuff
that we did then but I can personally
say that when I was a journalist and I
went to America for 10 years I never did
anything that was in any way illegal
yeah unlawful and there was nothing that
I couldn't defend doing and I think a
lot of other where it all went wrong was
people started to do that mmm and you
better stop me at some point what I was
just thinking like you describing your
fight with James O'Brien you're like
Rocky and he is Apollo Creed yes he
hasn't got a very good punch people have
come to listen to my show not least
because you know obviously I tend to
meet more of a break sits here even
though I actually didn't vote in the
referendum at all because I don't vote
it's one of the things that I choose not
to do I mean in order to be a proper
journalist why not because it ought to
be a proper journalist I think you
actually do have to be neutral and you
can't be neutral if you vote and when
people say to me yeah but hang on you
know surely you need representation you
need to you know put your kind of mark
on it on a piece of paper and and become
part of the the population I say not
really because I think if I'm voted
conservative after a race in labor if I
voted leave or I voted remain I couldn't
honestly kind of you know carry on a
conversation about what should happen
but you do have strong views oh don't
you I mean you are Pro brexit right one
of the reasons I'm Pro breaks it is
because the people voted to leave the
European okay so that's my motivation if
they'd voted to remain in it I would
have said well then that's what we have
to do you know your pride democracy I'm
trying to see you know a lot of people
think that that's just me hiding behind
you know a banner but it's not you know
and and also as I started to talk more
and more about BRICS I got more and more
fed up with the kind of remain sort of
elite they're the people that ran the
newspapers the people that ran the TV
stations and all of the kind of nonsense
that was coming from the pro remain
lobby and I had many many rounds with
with lots of MPs
we had this tent daily Westminster and
they would come in and some of them were
just so condescending about you know how
everything was going to be terrible and
basically what they were really saying
was that the stupid people have somehow
voted for this you know they don't know
what they're doing and we know better
than they do and I started to get really
kind of wound up about that and so it
seemed to me that I should be one of the
standard and now I'm sort of seen as one
of the standard bearers of bravely which
is fine with me because it also I think
was a really important moment you know
for the country to actually have the
people deciding what to do rather than
all of those people sitting in
Westminster because they would have
loved to have stayed in European Union I
still actually don't know why I mean I
know which way you guys voted but I
don't understand
people who say to me it's a great thing
to be an EU I don't you know I don't get
it what's so great about it
well we both voted remain because we're
good people that was a running joke on a
show for such a long time because we
voted remain but we are very much in
your camp in a sense that people vote
and and that that's it yeah and
democracy is far more precious than a
few even if you think that practice it
would be economically damaging which I'm
not sure about I don't think it will be
I mean it could be any number of things
could be I mean rotavirus could be a lot
more damaging than bricks it but also
staying in the you could be incredibly
economically damaging to and no one ever
thought about that but anyway my point
is you know just for voted remain we
lost there's never been in my experience
a more kind of collection of bad losers
I mean I've never seen like we were
sitting in Westminster on a day-to-day
basis and at one point actually a guy
called John rental he probably knows the
independence political commentator sat
down and I literally said to him you
know I've actually run out of questions
I can't I can't think of any to RT you
know because what you know what are we
going to do I thought we were going to
be stuck in this kind of horrendous hell
hole of nothingness going nowhere not
being able to do anything not be able to
pass any any bills not being able to get
any votes through I honestly didn't see
an ending I thought would just be doing
this forever but as it turns out
everybody else didn't agree and so when
the election time came I mean I didn't
expect Boris Johnson to win by that much
but it was fantastic I mean I just
remember as I'm I'm I wouldn't say
terrified of Jeremy Cole would becoming
Prime Minister but I wouldn't like it
Labour government I don't think I would
enjoy a left-of-centre Labour government
because apart from anything else they
would probably shut down the bits of the
media they don't like they would
certainly not be very pleasant to parts
of the Rupert Murdoch Empire I'm sure
because already you know a lot of them
don't speak so that anybody in the
building that I work in you know so I'm
very concerned that that what happens
next in Labour Party will be more of the
same because you know if they were ever
to get into power because Boris Johnson
screwed something up you know where
would we be then I don't think it's good
to see you remaining politically
yeah yeah because I say tepee it's on my
Twitter it says it's the most balanced
show on the radio and so whenever
anybody says it's not I said well look
it says it on Twitter I must but we
wanted to talk about the by media
independence and balance you get media
independence and balance cuz what I
think breaks it exposed and we touched
on it was the fact that there seems to
be this schism between the media class
and the average working person on the
street man woman and how actually more
more people are becoming less more and
more disenfranchised with the media yeah
why do you think now I think a lot of
those is there is because of the
individuals who are working in the media
because you know I'm old enough to
remember when when I first went into
newspapers newspapers were not full of
public skilled boys and girls you know
it was it was it was a trait a lot of
people went into local newspapers
because their father was in it or
because you know it was quite a good
apprenticeship you could go in to do a
journalism course when you were 16 you
could become a reporter indentured but I
say the local newspaper in Hastings or
in Cardiff or someone like that and they
were just ordinary members of the
community and they didn't go and work in
the community that covered the local
council meetings and then they'd sort of
move up to Fleet Street and all that
what we've got now it seems to me is
some very highly educated people who
have all been to Oxbridge at some point
or other and if not they've been they've
got a degree in something or other you
know and they've all become part of this
same establishment it's a sort of
separate establishment to the
establishment but the media for me
should be anti-establishment
you know you shouldn't be part of it you
shouldn't be sitting there going oh I'd
really like to end up you know running a
quango I'd really love to end up in the
House of Lords for services to
journalism I'd rather be sticking two
fingers up to them you know I don't want
anything from them I want to hold them
to account and I don't think enough
people really do that and somehow
there's been this kind of cult of
personality where you'd look at people
like Paul Mason you know who's a great
example of someone who was meant to be a
economics journalist and I think he
worked nice even remember he was
economics correspondent for the Channel
4 News and then he suddenly became his
labor activist then he come he go well
what is which one of these things are
you and actually at least you knew what
where he was coming from these things
have gone completely mad
you know he's out with placards warning
about this and the other he's now
left have now turned on him for being
not left enough Paul Masson yeah no he's
not no because apparently has been
talking about Kirsten Alma being the
answer right all the people that want
Rebecca long Bailey to get the job all
will work were rather keen on Jerry yeah
I think he's basically come out against
Corbin what's left of Starling I know I
know
well something's gone wrong but I think
you know when you watch people are added
Bolton and you watch people on Sky
generally you know they're very remaini
you know whether they think they are or
not they absolutely are you know and the
news agenda that they choose to follow
tends to be very much ruined by that and
I think that's the problem unlike you
know genuinely civil people who try to
be and I know that people accuse me of
being you know a Tory and all of that
but actually if the Tories do something
wrong I'll criticize them for I won't
find reasons not to I won't find another
story to do you know but there were so
many cases during the the remained
campaign and the leave campaign where
after that after the referendum you know
I remember the BBC doing a story about
Northern Ireland saying that basically
all that all the cattle would have to be
slaughtered you know if this congruent
went through with Boris Johnson and with
no backstop and they actually had to
apologize for it the next day because it
turned out to be complete enough the
nonsense the nfu came out and said when
were you getting this from but it's
complete rubbish we will not have to
slaughter all the castle
you know just stuff like that your basic
politics and basic journalism getting it
wrong like that question time as well I
mean you go to question time and I
watched you die just to get know it you
know necessarily can't see any merit in
it really at all and they're so
desperate to try and the other thing
about balance I think I remember who
said there's someone in America who said
you know balance is not about giving
equal time to absolutely everyone cuz
there are some right nothing's out there
you don't necessarily want to equate one
person's thought process with another
and so the person who said this in
America said you know if you're trying
to be balanced if somebody says to you
it's raining you know you don't get
somebody on who says it's raining and
somebody only says it's not rating you
look out the window and you decide
whether it's raining or not and then you
tell the people whether it's raining you
know you don't necessarily take every
single view and just repeat it as if
it's you know gospel because we know
that the people who want to be in the
media now are on the media are very
sophisticated now you know people are
very good at spinning stuff and you
think the media is hit this point of
crisis now you look at the mainstream
media and we I mean we were talking you
know the Sun declared record losses of
68 million pounds what is the purpose of
the mainstream media do we need it
anymore well I think politically
speaking it's nowhere near as
influential as it used to be I mean I
was watching Prime Minister's Questions
the other week and having a conversation
with someone saying even even parliament
is actually less relevant now in a way
than it used to be you know Prime
Minister's Questions is no longer what
it used to be you know the debates in
Parliament are no longer where they used
to be because you feel as though
everything's kind of already preordained
it's already stitched up you know all
the decisions are being made now in
Downing Street they're not really going
to Parliament to debate them they now
don't even have to because everything's
going to be passed through I think it's
a I don't I mean I can't imagine any
newspaper being responsible for Boris
Johnson getting a incredible ATC
majority I don't think you could you
could point to any one columnist that
was that was formerly powerful you know
I think as as entities they're still you
know part of something but they won't
last forever in and I think you guys
doing what you do me doing what I do in
a smaller way perhaps but also we're
doing a lot of stuff on YouTube now you
know there's many more people watching
YouTube now have just been turned off TV
all together really because actually you
have to ask yourself the real you know
why do you watch the news at ten' why do
you watch I mean I watched Channel four
News
generally speaking also just to kind of
get annoyed I've been very happy to see
that Jon Snow's been self isolated
apparently went to Iran to cover the
elections and he came back and he's now
self isolated he doesn't present news
anymore they just cross to him every
time that the news is on and he talks
from his kind of you know hellhole where
every lives pretty somewhere around here
and looks doesn't very well so but I
mean I don't really watch it to be
informed about anything I know and I
don't finish watching didn't think that
was a really really interesting you know
item about something and I've got a lot
of time for a lot of journalists so
particularly the ones who go into war
zones and you know individuals who
actually are they
that I respect and there's lots of them
and don't get me wrong there's lot
something to work at the BBC there's not
sort of work in Fleet Street there's
lots of them that work it all over the
place but but the entities themselves I
think is sort of confused as to what as
to where they go next cuz they can't do
what you guys do and they can't really
do what I do because you know they they
don't announce it well then the thing
the reason they can't do what we do is
cuz they're on the leash yeah we don't
have a leash on us we can not at the
moment
but I mean off come would very much like
to put a leash on YouTube and on social
media as well which is actually quite
terrifying it is it is and YouTube
itself would like to put a leash on
everybody that and we've we've talked
about a dozen times but I think in terms
of what you're talking about is it
really looks to me like the mainstream
media are kind of there they keep
clutching at things quite awkward leave
because they it's they're dying yeah and
they're like trying to grab on and
that's why you get these things like the
Kathy Newman Jordan Peterson is where
it's just worthless right it's basically
talking to a guy who has a massive
following whom those people who follow
him think he's great she's kind of
introducing him to everybody else he
doesn't know about him because they
don't go on YouTube and they don't
really know who he is and in the space
of the short interview time that they've
got they can't really work out who he is
and as you say that I don't think
anybody learned anything from that well
the only thing people learn is that he
he was good at arguing and she looked
like an idiot yeah yeah that's it I
don't think that's worth it's not the
only place you could look for that
conclusion but talking about the
mainstream media you brought up the BBC
or coming on times that was one issue
that we really wanted to talk to you
about obviously the Boris Johnson is
looking at removing the licence fee
making it a subscription-based model
what you're quite critical of yes yeah
you know well I think the BBC's too big
a part for anything else I mean what
it's meant to do and what it was
invented to do was to produce you know
broadcast of all material leader for the
radio or for television at a time when
that was really they were the only
people who could do it you know when
they invented you know radio for when it
was called the home service and I used
to listen to it my mother uses the
arches you know every night and it's a
day program you know it was good because
there wasn't much else to listen to
there wasn't much else out there you
know and it was very well
the news everybody watch the news at six
o'clock because that was how you found
out what was going on but now you don't
if you don't know what's going on at six
o'clock you must have literally been
asleep all day you know because
everybody now knows they're getting
alert on the phone when something
happens I mean you know during the
coronavirus scenario you're getting
alerts going on all the time you know
this has happened well that's happened a
few more cases over here I mean if
you're really not able to see any of
that and you get to six o'clock and you
go oh my god you know living in a cave
or something yeah
and also I've looked at what what it is
that they do they employ 22,000 people
all right they've got 61 radio stations
now I was at one of my incarnations was
running a radio station at Aaron Burr
the first speech license that was given
out since lbc back in 1973 and it didn't
work in the end because it was it was
smothered by BBC Scotland BBC Scotland
is this massive huge organization with a
great big office on the banks of the
Clyde in Glasgow employs hundreds of
people and so commercial operators can't
get a get a better look in you know you
cannot run a commercial radio station
for speech in this country because of
the BBC you know they've got a BBC
Sussex BBC Surrey
BBC Kent you know all in a very small
part of the South East of England three
different stations completely different
programming completely different
presenters I mean it's a nonsense and
they for me that should all go I'm quite
happy for them to keep the news
operation because I think some of it's
still very good but you know why the
hell do they do strictly for example you
know what is the BBC doing making a
programme about dancing in which they
paid loads of money to individuals to
appear on it I don't get it you know
that's not what the license is for as
far as I'm concerned and why do they
have such a massive website you know
what are they doing making children that
you have ten TV stations ten channels
which they don't need they were supposed
to have shut down BBC three still seems
to be going they're commissioning stuff
now just for the iPlayer and it's just
it's just too big I think it just needs
to be broken down so you want to make it
leaner but are you saying we should
abolish the licence yeah absolutely yeah
but do you know think that he should pay
for the bits of it that you want yeah so
I would do the reason I ask is like I
and I'm someone who who's gone on the
BBC a number of times usually to
criticize the PC so I'm not a huge fan
right on the one hand on the other hand
I do think that
we do need one national broadcaster
we're in a very polarized politically
society we can all come together and and
what they need to do is kind of be more
balanced because they haven't been
they've taken the piss on something but
if they could be more balanced on that I
think they could actually bring people
together into a common space otherwise
we just all disappear in a linkage oh
yeah I mean how do you Neal made that
point he came back from America I think
it was sometime last year and he said
you know I watched TV when I was there
and he knows America he works over there
a lot and he said I watched a program on
MSNBC which was a full guest talking
about what a horrible man Donald Trump
was and then I went over to Fox and
there was four people talking on a chat
show there about what a great guy Donald
Trump was he said here's what you should
do why don't you take two of them out
inside put them in the same show and
they can have a proper argument and like
you're right I don't I don't want to see
British media becoming polarized so that
only some people watch this and other
people watch that but the problem is is
that you know who decides what the BBC
does right I mean if you were to be the
guy that said now we're going to make X
number of shows we can have this many
channels we were employed this many
journalists I mean what is it what is it
though is it is it an entertainment
vehicle is it a news vehicle you know
what is it how would you how would you
how would you change you well it's a
combination of feel those doesn't them
which is maybe why you say it's too big
well me see I mean in my view when I was
growing up I'm a lot older than you guys
I was watching things like porridge and
dad's army and all that there was
literally nothing else going on I mean
there were three channels I remember
when there was only two channels you
know and long before they brought four
and five in and you didn't have a
massive choice and Saturday night the
family sat down and you basically
watched TV from about 6 o'clock at night
so we'll match the day finished you know
but people don't do that anymore
and variety comes in in many different
ways you know people will watch your
show rather than watch TV you got a
smart TV now you can watch YouTube on it
and it's just as good you know you don't
need to spend a fortune on making peaky
blinders somebody else can do that
you know Netflix can make peaky blinders
why is the BBC spending a fortune doing
it you know so I just think that the
model of basically telling people that
you must buy this otherwise we'll put
you in prison
you know it's supposed to be fun right
yeah you know you imagine somebody from
Netflix telling I'm going you don't have
a Netflix subscription so we're gonna
arrest you now you know in this day and
age I don't think it's just a funny is
quite a regressive if you look at it as
a tax yeah it is very regressive right
and it's you know people you know on the
one hand will say all but it you know it
works out you know about 12 pounds a
month or something like that well that's
quite a lot of money actually for for a
subscription you know I pay I think 1199
for Netflix because I've got all sorts
of members of my family disparate parts
of the world watching it you know but
you can get a subscription I think for
about $5.99 a month you know which is
less than half and that's the other bit
I don't care they've now launched this
thing called Brit box which is basically
their version of Netflix they started in
America and it's BBC and ITV together
they're supposedly going to be
commissioning shows for it but they're
also carrying old shows that would
otherwise reveal to places like Netflix
so they're actually asking you to
subscribe to something you've already
paid for so you can watch peaky blinders
you know as a boxer but you've already
paid for that why would you pay again so
watch it somewhere else it's just it's
just it's so wrong it seems to me it's
too big it's a bit like the NHS you know
bits of it work very well lots of it
doesn't work at all and they need to
just you know trim those bits off I
think and if they and if they say that
the people want them and a lot of people
say or what local radio is really
important well NoCal radio is important
but it should also be commercialized you
know I think a commercial company should
have the opportunity to start up a radio
station if they want to in Birmingham
but you've got you know BBC West
Midlands there and you know you've
probably got BBC Shropshire coming in
from the side you've got you know BBC
Bedford I mean you know that you can't
literally BBC York the BBC Darby I could
go on and on I mean you cannot you
cannot possibly justify that I don't
think you know and they've also killed
off the local newspaper industry as a
general rule as well because they have
now kind of taken over as that as the
thing that local people go to if they
want to look at stuff they've got local
website all they've all got websites and
so all the news that's happening in your
local area if you live in Derby is on
the BBC local website and
you know so newspapers can't get any
traction there either
hi guys we've got a returning sponsor
this week which is beard 52 that's beer
52 calm now before any we go any further
you might notice we are in a little bit
of a different environment and that's
because we're in my bedroom or is it
otherwise now ladies the pleasure done
we're 52 have got a wonderful offer fee
where you can get eight delicious craft
beers for a fiver that's a delicious
craft beers for five pound what can you
get for five pounds maybe a pint in
London maybe six chicken nuggets I mixed
chicken nuggets the great thing about
beer 52 is that every month they'll send
you a different case of beers from a
different part of the world recent
themes have included Germany the Alps
career what is the Alps even a country
now this is no country so if you want
access it's incredible awful all you
need to do is go to www.youtube.com
forward slash trigger and you'll get
those eight delicious beers direct to
your door what else are you gonna do and
where do you stand on the BBC the bias
within the BBC do you think it's a
fundamentally biased organisation I
don't actually I mean I think some
individuals have got is a bit like sort
of Noam Chomsky says you know nobody is
unbiased you know no matter where you
come from you have a kind of inbuilt
bias so there's no point in pretending
that we're all sort of these pure people
who don't have any prejudices or don't
have any kind of you know leave me for
yourself or don't have any leanings well
but everybody has a view of the world
right now if you try and disguise that
in some way and try and make out that
you know your view of the world is as
pure thing which has come from your
ability to be completely nothing mutual
I would say talking absolute bollocks no
but I think there are certainly
different ways of interviewing that if
different people do I mean I'm a big fan
of Andrew Nichols for example but I
don't think that what his you know he
did that sort of piece to camera about
Boris Johnson not coming on his show I
didn't think that was necessary I
thought
kind of slightly demeaned him really
yeah I thought I was really good yeah
see a lot people did I thought it was
unnecessary because the reason for doing
it was slightly petulant slightly
self-obsessed
slightly going you know how is he not
coming on my show you know everybody
knows that my show is the most important
show during any election period because
I'm the only person who can hold into
account and he made a series of
allegations about him without him being
able to answer them now you might argue
well Johnson should have gone and done
the interview but I don't think it's the
BBC's place to kind of do that like
they're all kicking off at the moment is
that the misters are not going on the
day program because they've said that
today program is very biased they don't
want to do it so they've become slightly
less relevant now you know it's a day
program when I was a journalist in Fleet
Street was always the show you listen to
in the morning driving into the work
because it was the one that would give
you all the stuff he needed to know and
it's where all the ministers were now
that they're not doing that people are
listening to other stuff but that speaks
to Francis point about bias because in
those days that program would have been
edited by Rod little yeah right and this
would never happen now would you say if
you listened to the program but the rod
little was editing that somehow it was
biased towards the Tories I don't think
you would know his glory anyway is a guy
who can actually be reasonably neutral
in his job you know what we beat would
be considered a right-wing newspaper
come on and he's a pro brexit guy but I
mean I spoke to him about Briggs it a
long time ago and he said to me you know
when the morning after the referendum
result his wife went to get take the
kids to school and they live in a sort
of leafy part of the country and she
said to me yeah yeah I came back from
from the school gates and she said
everyone was saying we can't believe
this has happened you know because we
don't know anybody that voted to leave
oh really
well that's surprising you know that's
because you're in a Volvo you're in Kent
and you're in a very nice affluent part
of the country where you've got your
kids in private school well it's not
very surprising is it you know but they
literally didn't get it and I think
that's part of the problem the BBC that
they because they live in this kind of
rather nicely upholstered world you know
whether it's in London or elsewhere
they're all paid ridiculous amounts of
money but everyone mentioned that
there's an icon Steven Nolan right who
gets five hundred thousand quid a year
he works in Northern Ireland he came
he covers for a radio 5 but you know
it's ludicrous money I mean I can say
that because I'm not on 500,000 pounds a
year but I'm actually Balinese you might
say he's no bigger audience but you know
that's not the point
yeah how does he get half a million quid
that is not in any way shape or form
market value
he left the BBC he would not get that
money in a where else you could buy most
not know but it's become it's been sort
of knocked out of kilter with reality
here's the problem and so I think they
will sit around talking to each other
Fiona Bruce is a good example I think
Fiona Bruce is probably quite a good
presenter of the Antiques Roadshow but
what the hell
how does she end up doing the best and
supposedly most interesting political
show as well you can't you know how can
you do that I mean she was a newsreader
okay
so I've got nothing as for you at Bruce
but you know when she presents a
question time she interrupts people who
tend to be from the Tory party far more
than she interrupts with anna-lena party
and it's very irritating and they all do
it the interrupting thing is really all
for one of the things that I like about
these kinds of shows is that you're not
sitting there trying to interrupt me all
the time you know and I'm not trying to
interrupt you you let you let people
talk and I know that they don't have
perhaps the time that we have but is
there's a lot of sort of nitpicky type
journalism that goes on where they get
somebody on and they've clearly got and
rumari's is the king of this he's
clearly got one question he wants to ask
he's very proud of it and that's what
they're all hoping to make the bulletin
you know they're all hoping to get
somebody to admit to something or to
screw something up you know or to you
know to tell a lie and it's kind of what
I would call kind of hijacking
journalism you know it's it's sort of
trying to ambush people all the time I
think what they don't understand sir yes
about that but well I think they don't
understand this just a quick point
before is that they're damaging the
brand yeah
the brand of their their company whether
it's a BBC or its Channel four with
Kathy Newman either or whether it's the
broader brand of journalism they're
damaging the brand by doing that and
they're contributing to their own deaths
but yeah and I think actually I mean if
you look at what Trump's done and I'm no
particular fan of Donald Trump but and I
found it very distasteful when you would
see those press conferences that he
would have
with his supporters at them all kind of
doing this you know to the journalists
and you know threatening them and stuff
and making out that the journalists of
the enemy and he really fed into that
and he really made the people who were
there feel that way that the journalists
were definitely the enemy and I think
there's a bit of that going on at the
moment with down history because I think
Dominic Cummings is very much about
making the journalist appears to be the
enemy and I think he's been quite
successful I mean if you watch the way
he operates in terms of those little
snippets you get of people following
around in the street and he just says
something ridiculous you know like you
said that thing about the kids shown the
masks and you know he looks at you could
ask me stupid questions all night and
he's walking away from them and he's
treating them really with absolutely
nothing disdain you know but I've never
been a fan of politicians being allowed
to have you know these kind of staged
events but they were all doing it now I
mean the Labour Party were doing it as
well and they would boo when the BBC
would get up and speak you know it's
it's really it's a sort of it's a kind
of nasty atmosphere that's been that's
been created I think largely by the by
the the fault of the journalists for
being too biased but also the faulkner
politicians for encouraging you know
their supporters to feel you know kind
of aggressive against journalists and so
it's a really good point that you're
making because you do see that and there
isn't a relatively recently yeah and
we've come to this point where we seem
to be polarized and you know you get
people openly booing journalists and
both sides of the argument saying the
BBC a fundamentally Airboss brexit BBC B
you know breaks it broadcasting of
cooperation all the rest of it how do we
bring some kind of unity back to journal
well you see I'm not one of those you
hear this all the time now that you know
for those who defend the BBC well if
they're being attacked by the left and
the right for being biased they must be
doing something right no they must be
doing something [ __ ] wrong everyone
thinks it's a good [ __ ] job you know if
you are a painter a decorator and
everybody's criticizing you you don't go
see shows you what a great painter and
decorator I am no it means you're not
doing it right
and I think the BBC needs to stop being
quite so quite so pompous I think they
could do with giving their their
journalists their senior journalists
anyway a kind of a shake-up because I
think they all think that they're God's
gift to everything you know and they're
there and they're the only ones that
know anything and they're very snobby
about everybody else and if you're not
in the BBC you know people just looking
yo what you work for Murdoch oh god you
know how awful must that be or you know
you work for the mirror or you work for
the Express or you work for ITN you know
there's a kind of snobbery I think they
I think they have to just strip it all
down and start again and have a real
conversation an honest conversation with
themselves about what it is that they
think they should be doing and they
should realize that actually the
majority of people in this country are
ordinary sort of lower middle class
individuals who work for a living you
don't really care that much about the
transgender debate they don't hear about
it ad nauseam they don't really care
that much about LGBT they don't want
anyone's to be horrible to anybody but
they just don't want to have stuff
talked about endlessly which is a minor
issue or which is what most people would
consider to be you know a minority issue
shall we say I mean there's interesting
study that came out the other day about
LGBT and be am a representation on
broadcast media and on television it
turns out that it's actually
over-represented now of course you know
it's not actually in any way
representative of the percentage of the
population it's over represented by a
factor of about double the right which
again I don't really care about but
somebody's doing that yeah somebody's
making that happen you know like when
you have a transgender character in
Coronation Street right you kind of go
in okay well that's fine but you know
why did you have to do that you know why
did you have to have a transgender
character you know and it's it just
feels a little bit forced all the time
and I think that's the problem I think
everybody's been trying to be too
inclusive mmm-hmm and they've forgotten
what the majority of people actually are
quite like in the pejorative in this
country are not racist they're not
horrible they're not nasty they're
fair-minded and they just want I think
their television so represent you know
their lives and I think it's moved it's
so far away from that that they don't
really feel that it's it's for them
anymore it's like we don't know where to
stop right with all the stuff so I
remember there was an article about how
the BBC plans to make sure that I think
it was like 20% of on-screen talent are
gay lesbian or whatever and I was like
why on earth would they want to reduce
the number of gay people on TV I mean so
the it's not to say that making sure
that people are properly represented is
necessarily a bad idea but
you've got to make sure as you say that
it's representative of the population as
opposed to an endless drive to just make
sure that everyone on TV is LGBT yeah I
mean well I mean funnily enough
Christopher Biggins came on to radio a
while back around the time Paul Scofield
came out you know the shocking and brave
and big it was hilarious because he's
basically saying you know when he
started working at CP you know you
couldn't be gay there was absolutely no
way you could admit so he says now if
you're not go you got no chance to get
on but I've been told by various people
in the business well you know forget
about getting on TV because you're white
and you're male you know it's not gonna
happen
and so you know like you I've appeared
as a sort of talking head from time to
time but I mean nobody's ever gonna give
me a TV show the BBC nobody's ever gonna
give me you know a job reading the news
or anything like that because I'm not
the right sort of you know concept for
them you know because I might I might
have a few views that they don't agree
with you know this is the other thing
that people now are much less tolerant
of other people's views you know if you
disagree with me that's great
we can have a conversation about it you
know it's called a debate but now if you
go on television with views which are
considered to be you know horrible even
though they might not be horrible they
don't want to put you on they will never
for example Kelvin Mackenzie more or
less never allowed now on question time
they used to go on it quite a lot now
you can take a view of Kelvin Mackenzie
of what sort of a guy he is but you know
why should he not be able to go on TV
the reason is because so many interest
groups have said this is a monster you
know we can't have him he's responsible
for all the hot the horrors of the world
and so the BBC just goes you know what
it's easier if we don't put him on and I
think there's a lot of that going on
there's a lot of kind of you know
pushing of certain agendas a lot of
pushing of certain you know cultural yet
yeas and nays and so the BBC try and
kind of keep to what they think they
should be doing to attract the least
sort of anger from groups you know
because there are certain groups of
people who are much more vociferous than
others right and so if you do have I
mean I think one of the greatest things
that ever happened to example was when
that guy from the BNP went on question
time
quickly Nick Griffin I mean that was the
end of him he went on he went on
question time he made a complete fool of
himself
didn't know what he was saying and his
political life pretty much ended that
night you know so I'm all for showing
people like that up put them on put him
on the air making him look idiotic and
making everybody realize that actually
this is not very clever guy after all
and maybe he's not really worth
listening to and that was literally that
was it for him you know we're delighted
to have a brand new sponsor for those of
you who are interested in learning a
foreign language mate we've got a
predominately British audience none of
them are gonna be interested in learning
a foreign language
yeah that's true also no one is really
traveling right now it's a foreign
countries let's be honest but when when
the coronavirus is over those of you who
are still left on this planet might be
interested in second language and that's
why Babel is a great place for you
Babel is great because they have a
website and an app which allows you to
learn a new language with 10-15 minutes
snippets every day in a clear and simple
way which is great for people like
Francis who are simple absolutely and
also as well when you're in quarantine
what else you gonna do you can try Babel
completely free simply head over to
babble dodo UK or download the app and
you can try it completely free that's
right guys go on to www.sba.gov
we were talking about all these thing at
lgbtq beim all the rest of it and we
talked a lot about diversity yeah but
isn't one of the major problems that we
don't actually have diversity because
real diversity is diversity of opinion
yes and we don't seem to have it I think
a lot of it is diversity of class as
well which we don't have only one of the
things you see with almost every a black
and an ethnic person on major
broadcasting shows they're all very
middle and upper-class
you know they've all been to private
school you know isn't it we're not
getting the equivalent Stahl's II you
know coming on the one show and
presenting it you're getting the
equivalent of you know basically Andrew
Marr who went to school privately and
who went to the nice universities who
happens to be brown you know so they're
not actually representative of anything
other than the same class of people and
you're absolutely right and if you don't
have a diversity of opinion
we know it's laughing at the Oscar
ceremony right because suddenly a movie
from South Korea wins called what's
Harris Harris on which is meant to be a
brilliant film sure it is but everyone's
raving about we sit great to have all
this diversity at the Oscars and I'm
looking at the mall standing on the
stage and there's you've let some South
Koreans in yeah yeah I'm sorry that's
wrong yeah you know it's a crazy time
but let's move on to the political
landscape and kind of in broad
brushstrokes obviously as we mentioned
and joked about earlier the Labour Party
she's kind of disappearing ah yeah but
they're more and more and more
irrelevant it seems to me yeah I think
one I don't really know what they stand
for and they don't either no I don't
think they do and it's actually
frightened of saying what they stand
from yeah I mean the thing I find most
amusing about them is whenever anybody
asks them about you know who was your
favorite Labour leader and they're all
so desperate to avoid saying Tony Blair
they have a dance around all this I mean
parole term Rebecca long Bailey they
said to her you know who's the old
favorite for the last 50 years and she
named Clement Attlee who died like 60
years before so if one of them would
actually come out and say with some
honesty look we can't mean we should say
Tony Blair because he won three
elections but we can't say Tony Blair
because he basically betrayed us and he
took us into this illegal war and
therefore he will never be regarded as a
great man but they don't do that they
kind of talk around him like he didn't
exist like he was never there you know
well we've talked to Labour Party to
death on the show but let's look at the
concerns because Boris Johnson has
obviously been elected on a large base
of working-class people from former
Labour heartlands how do you see the
kind of the job that he's doing how do
you you'll get a lot of those kind of
people calling into your show I imagine
yeah well actually I mean we've got an
audience of what I would say are more
brexit party types right people who were
driven to vote for breaks in whichever
way shape or form they could some labour
some of them are working-class some of
the northern and I think a lot of them
are still for them the jury's out on
Boris you know they're going to wait and
see how it all goes
and I think I mean I think he's doing
better than people thought he might do
certainly before the election when he
was when he became Prime Minister and we
were told you know this is a man who you
know would basically sell his own mother
you know he's not to be trusted I mean I
found it quite distasteful that they
were talking about how terrible he was
with women I mean I don't really care
what he really what he's like with women
he's a peaked of up you know the fact
that he's left a couple of wives does
not mean he's not gonna be a good Prime
Minister and again you know people like
to sort of point fingers at guys like
Boris Johnson and say oh but look look
how horribly look what he did you know
he doesn't even know how many children
he's got to me none of that really
matters what matters is what he does
I've been a bit disappointed that he's
been so sort of green because I killed
him the Eco planks you know the
extinction rebellion crowds the people
that want to you know stop everything
and make everybody just walk around and
cycle everywhere and not actually get a
car not get on a plane and I'm really
disappointed that he hasn't kind of been
a bit less enthusiastic about that you
know the fact that he's now talking
about doing away with cars that are not
elektra by 2032 that's not that long
away I mean there are some ordinary
people who buy a car and keep it for ten
years there'll be people now thinking
well I was going to get a diesel but I
better not now because it's not gonna be
worth anything and so I've been a bit
I've been disappointed with that but of
course that's a very unpopular view
because that makes me you know some kind
of diners I don't have that some popular
because the thing with the diesels by
the way that pissed me off is I've
always had a diesel yeah the government
kept pushing deep people yeah and then
suddenly they're like the worst you know
is Ed Miliband that told everybody right
and the fact remains that you know he
has this majority and the only kind of I
suppose impediment to him being as
successful as he wants to be is his own
policy himself and himself I mean I
think one of the reasons why when when
we had the floods recently that he
wasn't going out there he's because he's
worked out that one if he does it he's
likely to run into none of those Labour
Stooges he's gonna turn up and say my
son's dying in hospital will he doing
about it and then miraculously recovered
as the next day all he does something
really idiotic I think there he falls
down a hole or he says the wrong thing
or somebody overhears him you know you
know
that bigoted woman moment so I think
they've worked out as they did you in
the election keep him sort of quite as
far away from the press because he's
actually people said you know Boris is a
brilliant orator I mean people do like
it but it's not a great orator no not a
brilliant debater I mean they basically
had me call Ben I didn't think he was
that good no and to me that one thing
that is going to define Boris's term
this well his forty or five-year term
whatever it is is going to be the
question of immigration yeah and that is
what people a lot of people voted for
wouldn't brexit yeah pretty patellas
come out so they're gonna be incredibly
tough on immigration
yeah do you think he's actually gonna
commit to it or do you think he's glad
to the issue I think it's gonna be a
fudge because the problem is that an
awful lot of businesses have already
kind of turned their backs on it and
said well hang on it's all very well for
you to say as Priti Patel did well you
know just hire some local people and pay
more money and people are going well you
know I can't do that because I won't
make any money then and what I do make
you'll be taxing me one of the greatest
errors I think that they ever made the
Tories was giving the Chancellor's job
to George Osborne I think probably the
worst Chancellor at all time who's put
taxes up massively I mean I run a small
business my taxes are more or less
doubled in the time that you know I've
been running the business and last say
ten years you know because they've
changed the way that they tax small
business they've gone after individuals
who are the wealth creators of this
country and then the Tories you know
this is what I'm terrified low point
getting because I mean this lot of done
padded up but I think that you know for
example the fruit pickers that would
come in from Eastern Europe on on an
annual basis sometimes maybe would stay
for the rest of the year you know you're
not going to find people indigenously
here in this country who are living here
who are going to want to do that kind of
work so they're apparently they're going
to give some dispensation to see the
fruit growers so that they can import
these people so so you can figure out
that one all right first of all they're
also now going to forget the 30 thousand
threshold for people coming in so that
if your work at the NHS you can come in
so you'll forget that one and so you
know I think it's a good idea to have a
points-based system but whether it
actually practically means anything I
don't know and every single government
that said they're going to crack down on
immigration
somehow fails to do something and it
ends up with more people coming in and I
think will happen with this because the
way they've set up the point system I
mean I think it allow
a lot of people to come until this
country yeah which I personally don't
have a huge problem with but there are
people who do so and people voted to
have a reduced you know I think the
interesting thing is is that you know
it's it's categorized and framed by the
Labour Party as a as a racist issue
right which it really isn't because most
of the people who voted to control the
borders voted about people coming from
the EU particularly from Eastern Europe
you know that was their main concern
they're not that bothered about the
family of Asians who have been there for
three generations living down the road
you know I mean there are racist people
in this country who might be up against
people with different coloured skin but
by and large it was the Eastern European
sort of influx of people that came
because of course that European Union is
now a very different animal so what it
was you know when you when I mean I
remember I used to before I got a dog he
used to go to Calais quite a lot from
Sussex we'd go and take a day trip over
to Carrefour and buy some wine and pate
and pretend we were European and you
know coming up back on the ferry one
time there was a group of Romanians and
and they were standing on the on the
deck and when the White Cliffs of Dover
came in they needed treatment jumping up
and down cheering because the you know
this was their kind of you know Nirvana
they'd suddenly found the place they
wanted to get to and they will go into a
van with Romanian plates and drove into
Britain then probably still here you
know because there's nothing wrong with
that there's nothing illegal about it
but I think the problem is is that if
you look at countries where people live
where the standard living is so poor
that they want to come here even to do a
terribly you know labor-intensive job
for not very much money but it's still
better than where they live of course
they're gonna come and they're gonna
want to stay and the reason that people
want to come to this country this is a
great country and the people who are
already here from the EU are all asking
for settled status you know two million
of them I mean we were told by that by
the romaine is that they were all going
to leave no they thought they all want
to stay because they love it you know
and I'm quite happy with that
but living in London it's a very skewed
prospects I mean I hear from people in
places like Peterborough and I've never
been to Peterborough so another one is
whether it's true but you know parity
Peter has got a very big check
contingent of people that went lived
there I would that wouldn't bother me
but I mean I can see how other people
might think you know it's not my turn
anymore and I think that's what the
government has to be careful about they
have to be they have to be aware that
some people think like that but it isn't
Boras aware anything to use his own
words that the vote was borrowed not
given and that he really needs to tackle
this because if he doesn't yeah
then well I cheat who else are they
gonna vote for well I mean that is the
problem I mean you know I obviously got
to know quite a few people in the
bracelet party I don't think there I
mean there was some talk that Nigel
Farage was going to have a silver you
know Reform Party we're gonna try and
reform politics that's not going to
happen I mean that's all gonna go away
because all of their funding gonna
disappear
but you're right you know yes people
will expect Boris to improve their lot
in life but I've always said and I said
this during the whole campaign of the
referendum you know people shouldn't be
you know relying on politicians to make
their lives good or bad because in the
end you know it's up to you what you do
with your life you know and yes a
politician can ruin it but I'm making
you pay too much tax or by you know
making you move to another country you
know but by and large your own life is
your own destiny and it's how you sort
yourself out how many children you have
and all of that it's nothing to do with
them so you shouldn't expect to be
handed money I don't think and I think
you should be expected to be provided
with a job and I know plenty of people
who live in a North East of England who
were perfectly happy with their lot it's
not as if you know there's this huge
swathe of poor people wandering about
you know without any clothes on their
back and no food to eat you know this is
Britain you know it's not you know
Siberia for want of a better roof place
to pick at random
you can't wander around inside but you
know I mean I think I think we sometimes
think that the the plate the people's
experiences are worse than they really
are
you know I mean item rail with lower
pitcock before the election about
poverty you know because we have this
figure of something like 14 million
people living in poverty in this country
I just don't it's not true it's relative
poverty as designed by the UN because
you know they take the average income
and they look at what people are making
you know there are not 14 million people
living in poverty in this country she
accused me of peddling right-wing myths
you know and then she didn't get elected
funnily enough though there are lots of
parts of the north of England which are
very prosperous which is full of
reasonable people making a reasonable
living running businesses you know and
yes and that but it looks already one of
the things that Boris has apparently
promised to do is to is deciphered more
money up to northern parts of the
country but we've seen all that before I
mean look what happened in in sulphate
when the BBC relocated to sulfur they
spent most of its aren't faring people
backwards and forwards from London
because nobody wanted to move north you
know if that's Susanna Reid ended up
leaving the BBC as a result going so I
see figures she just didn't want to live
there and I think yeah I mean it's
difficult to know how much the
government can improve the society in
which we live you know I mean hs2
another thing I think was a massive
mistake I don't really see the point of
hs2 and they're going to spend a hundred
billion plus it'll probably two hundred
billion by the time they're finished
so basically get from Birmingham to
Shepherds Bush in twenty minutes less
than you would normally have got to
Houston to dreadful car you know exactly
into town yeah you know I mean and they
talk about you know Crossrail this and I
mean I do agree that we should we have
been very bad in this country for a long
time as infrastructure that nobody's
looked more than five years ahead and
maybe in that case it's a good thing to
build this fast train but you know I'm
gonna be dead by the time it's ready
frankly you know it's not about it's not
all about me but you know mostly no
matter how much technology will have
moved on yeah in twenty years time you
know people might be in flying drones
you know been being moved around by you
know arrrooo but or something you know
and they're still gonna be cancellations
on air you know you're still gonna be
there what do you mean you cancel my own
yeah yeah you were to be mean right
where's the wrong Street yeah I mean you
know the point is is that you can't
imagine something that they think is
going to be absolutely you know
cutting-edge technology now is going to
be cutting edge technology in 2040 it's
just isn't you know well I suppose that
argument could always be made at any
part that's what people say it and they
go although that's what they said about
flowing and that's what they said about
actually it's not what they said about
flying because before you could fly the
fly you know why it was pretty [ __ ]
amazing so you could get from here to
New York you know in less than a week
yeah
when she'd have to take on you know so
it's not like that no but what I'm
saying is is that I mean bizarrely is
well the Green Party you're against it
which distress was slightly arts it's
they're meant to be again you know for
public transport and against you know
car travel but the Green Party or
against HS so yeah why
apparently because it goes through too
many areas of wetlands or you know it's
kind of mad and if you're gonna spend
that kind of money it seems to me how
about you build some houses for people
because people do need houses built in
places where they're not gonna get
flooded and in the places where they are
gonna get flooded do something about the
flooding yeah you know we don't need
another bloody train this is funny when
you were talking about Boris Johnson
messing up during the floods I just had
this image of him just like standing
over some kind of lever on a damned yes
accidentally fires it off like the whole
town I think he's actually less
accident-prone than he appears to be and
those people that I know that's not what
the women say me well he is a guy who is
very good at stage managing things yeah
I know some people who worked very
closely with him who's the mayor and you
know the roughly of the hair before he
goes on TV you know the kind of slightly
disheveled look it's all quite well
manufactured it's not it's not normal
and he's how if you look at his hair I
mean nobody's hair it looks like that
yeah the way that his hair kind of goes
in different directions he's got to be
putting something in it to make it do
that yeah I mean I know that I may not
have the greatest head of hair you know
quite old now and I'm not I'm not
showing to him is it but his hair does
not look normal and it doesn't grow like
that I'm sorry it just doesn't and you
know I just think he's much less
spontaneous than everybody thinks he no
thinks he is remember in fact it was a
not a he did a speech somebody was
telling this story if he was telling to
me I heard it on the radio talking to
somebody else he basically went to do a
sort of after-dinner speech and he
turned up late and he kind of shuffled
around and he just went into this kind
of random story about something or other
which was quite amusing and nothing
really much to do with the people that
were there for the night somebody then
saw him at another event where he did
exactly the same thing so exactly
same story and it was all reversed it
wasn't in any way spontaneous it wasn't
like I've forgotten my notes I've left
them on the train which is what he was
saying I'll just have to do it from
scratch this was a routine that he had
memorized and you know you guys I guess
do a bit of that so you know what that's
like I mean it's it's there's nothing
wrong with it you know if you have to do
an act and you have to you know I mean
talkSPORT made a massive error once and
I can talk about this because it was a
long time ago and the guys are not
working in there anymore but they booked
a Russell Brand near a show and then you
know it was when Russell was kind of
riding very high into popularity ratings
and he was basically on tour and so the
program directed its time said this
would be great you know because we can
put him on at ten o'clock on a Saturday
night and we'll just run it live every
every night not live but you know the
the Friday night recording whatever yeah
so the first one went out and over this
is great you know it's fantastic
brilliant the second one came in and he
had to listen to it first and he rang
the agent he said he said I think you've
sent me the wrong ones we have a problem
here he says it's the same as last week
and he went yeah that's that's the show
and he went what you mean we booked this
for ten weeks does the same show
everywhere he yeah he's a comedian he
goes to places and he tells basically
the same jokes and does the same routine
ever one run one episode because all the
others were the same but if you find
where these guys working now I'll say
these names financed a showing funny and
way to monetize it as you well know
we're well funded by the it's amazing
how people think you're funded isn't it
mean when you actually aren't funny
buddy what's over drop yeah yeah well
that's very good but yeah I mean the the
sort of the difference in the media
landscape now is is really quite
interesting for me because it's even
just in five years it's changed yeah and
I think it will continue to change which
is why to go out to the BBC I don't
think their model is sustainable yeah
you know because they can't possibly if
he was setting the BBC up now from
nowhere oh yeah you would not get to
where it is now it's just
would you join the EU now if you're in
independent Britain probably not but
just before we wrap up I guess and on
the political side of things as well as
Sadiq Khan is somebody yes you're not a
huge fan of no we wanted to talk about I
mean look one of the there is a couple
of issues that are happening in London
right now the they're just dreadful I
mean number one is obviously knife crime
yeah and number two is their man of
rough sleeping and homeless yes that you
see like we walk around this very
wealthy area and there's literally
people with tents yeah in the middle of
the recent thing isn't I'm a Londoner
and I've lived lived here the majority
of my life I don't remember that
happening when this city was actually
poorer yeah and there was in less wealth
I mean there was always like like you
said they were always kind of tramps as
we refer to them then their ruins people
that slept on park benches that normally
they wanted to you know for whatever
reason they were you know not all there
they were probably suffering from some
kind of mental problem but you know but
it was kind of their choice and then I
mean sort of down at Charing Cross it
started to get bad I guess about 20
years ago but it's much worse now yeah I
agree
there's money coming supposedly from the
government I spoke to a guy not long ago
about all of that and who goes around
helping particularly homeless veterans
because quite a lot of them as well and
it's very hard to know what is going on
I mean I think the other there is a
problem with with the sort of culture of
begging as well which I think has meant
that a lot of the people that you see
begging are not homeless but they then
impact on people wanting to give money
to the real homeless people you know and
certainly I know that there's been sort
of influx influx ins of people's and the
right word from you know from some of
the poorer parts of Eastern Europe
living I mean I think there was a there
was a wholesome tented village around
Marble Arch at one point which I never
saw but I saw pictures of and I don't
know what I tell you what you do about
it but London has become also a very
busy city for me I mean it's now never
quiet right I used to do is show that
finished at one o'clock in the morning a
Friday going into Saturday and I could
come out of the office and being a
traffic jam in the middle of New Cross
at 1:00 in the morning you know and I'm
not sure that Sadiq Khan can do much
about that I think what he's done I
think he's messed up the the
transportation system I think the row
a terrible terrible state he's
completely discouraged anyone from
driving but yet he's got 35,000 ubers
driving around at any given time you
know you know the tube trains that used
to be really good and very efficient and
no longer that you know and I think he
is a figure who sees himself as you know
the jobs too small for him you know he
thinks he should be Prime Minister he
thinks he should be President of the
United States or something I just don't
think he takes London seriously enough
and from looking at the way he operates
in the City Hall chamber he's very
arrogant you know he doesn't like people
questioning what he does we've asked him
at numerous times to come on her radio
show he's refused never does goes on
James O'Brien show all the time because
he quite likes it but he doesn't want to
come anywhere he's gonna be asked some
serious questions and you're right about
the knife crime he could have spent a
lot more money on police in London but
he chose to spend it on his PR machine
he chose to spend it on trips abroad you
know he was over in Europe wasn't he not
long ago asking people if they could
become honorary or associate members of
the European Union citizens of London
and citizens of Europe you know what was
all about you know we vote to leave you
know get lost and I think I think he's I
just don't think he's very good at bit
but I think you'd probably be reelected
because the Labour machine in London is
very very good you know but it's not
just knife crime I think there's a
crisis with policing yeah like my
parents house got burgled last year
yeah and they reported it a lot of very
valuable things got stolen and then they
didn't even investigate it they just
went the case is closed yeah yeah they
don't I mean I don't know what that's
all about to be honest I mean I was the
victim of a crime which when I tell you
what it was will make you laugh somebody
actually went into human life in
thinking about it went into my local dry
cleaners and stole my shirt yeah the
police wouldn't leave me alone though
yeah you know and I know stories like
yours which is which is proper you know
proper victims of crime I then
eventually they called me in for an
intern interview in sermons a police
station which is now closed by the way
because when I went there we were like
stepping over these the guards I'm
really sorry it's a bit of a mess we're
moving we're moving out
I'm not waiting moving so he's like what
we're not moving anywhere we just
shutting it down they're selling it
and I sat there with him for about an
hour talking about this crime and how I
felt about it and how it made me feel
and did I feel victimized by they've
really no guaranteeing they're gonna
give me free dry cleaning for as much as
long as I want and cuz I'm gonna have to
replace ten shirts it's fine you know
but yeah I don't know what's going on
with the police yeah they seem to have
the capability as they have done
recently to do these raids on the county
lines gangs and every now and again that
seems to work quite well the armed
police in London I think it brilliant
whenever there's any kind of terrorist
problem yeah they're so quick now I mean
I was in London Bridge the last time
there was an attack and you know the
speed with which the Reverend responds
guys get to things now he's really
amazing and I'm very very sort of
impressed with that but yeah but the
ordinary just you know making yourself
feel safe in a city which is what you
should feel I don't know what I don't
know what's gone wrong but I don't know
again whether that's a national problem
whether it's a Sadiq Khan but I think
Sadiq Khan could be much more proactive
yes about doing something about it he
should be saying this is the most
important thing that affects everyone in
the city instead of going off to Europe
and trying to get some kind of you know
associate do you think he's more
interested in his image and use in
helping in London I think so I think
he's the worst kind of politician which
is why I just don't have any time for
him I think he's only interested in
sound bites he's only interested in kind
of appealing to his base the people who
vote for him he's not that interested if
you don't vote for him and what you
think you know he doesn't really care
about your parents unless they vote for
him yeah you know maybe that's what they
should have done they should have called
up and said you know we vote fisted he
can't can you come and help us out so
Mike the last question we always ask is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about that we should be talking about
but maybe before we get to that you
obviously take a lot of calls from
members of the public what do you think
is the one issue that people are really
concerned about or interested in in the
kind of broader spectrum of things at
the moment that that you you feel like
all this this is an issue that's just
getting a lot of traction well I think
there's two really there's I would say
the the sort of the the
is a very big one because there's an
awful lot of people who hate the whole
idea that we know everything is turning
green and you know we've been told to
stop eating meat and driving around in
cars and not allowed to fly anywhere and
the hypocrisy of all of them and I think
there's you know there's a big backlash
now against the kind of woke generation
of people I think and a lot of ordinary
people have just said enough already you
know let's just like live our lives you
can be nice to one another but we don't
need to but there's a lot of people
telling us how to live and I think
there's a lot of distrust and distaste
about that and I think we've already
touched on the other origins immigration
I think people are genuinely worried
that this country is basically full up
now you and I both know that parts of
this country are completely desolate you
know if you go down to the west country
for example you know it's very white and
there's quite a lot of room you know
same as parts of Scotland I mean The
Scotsman was talking about how you know
we need to have an awful lot of
immigration because we've got a fully
birthrate you go to parts of Scotland
there's no literary don't be there
there's more sheep than there are people
you know so for anyone to say that you
know the country's overrun with with
anybody whether it's immigration or not
it's just not true but I think there are
certainly parts of the country where
people feel you know somehow that it's
hostile and whether that's right or
wrong that's one of those are the two
things I'd say that they get most worked
up about you know and crime as well I
mean you know if if you count probably
the the numbers of callers on any per
given subject there's always a lot
callers like you who would say well I
reported this to the police nothing
happened you know I even and we had a
guy once you said he had his motorbike
stolen and he knew exactly where it was
and he was behind he was in a garret in
a lock-up and he basically found it
because he had one of the tracker device
they wouldn't go there and I Hannah and
and make an opening up he said they were
like we don't have enough evidence but
it doesn't make people angry I mean you
talk about doing an hour interview of
the police about some shirts right I had
my car broken into I got a [ __ ] email
right yeah I got an email number and a
crime number yeah that's it yeah that's
the pulling power I mean it's just it's
just bizarre and and you know other
people have nice stories to tell about
because I think you could be very lucky
now
yeah to have a cop actually come around
your house and visit you and actually
investigate what may have happened you
know it's not a criticism of police
officers I don't know it's anything to
do them I think that my experience with
police officers in general is they're
incredibly conscientious decent
hard-working people who are in there for
the right reason there's obviously
something going on structurally the
prevent I mean I was asked the question
you know when they say we have enough
people you know but when there's a mark
let me know in the days you remember
those days when people used to march for
Briggs ooh much for romaine or whatever
it was it was always loads of cops yeah
and they all somehow managed to find
20,000 police who were willing to do
overtime so I mean you know there's
something not quite right there's enough
police I think they're just not being
you know policed in the right way
themselves and given the right job you
know do you think do Peter Hitchens is a
big fan of this that they should be out
on the beat I think seeing them is a
good thing yeah you know I don't expect
them I mean again I remember the days
when they they used to drive around
those little panda cars you know and
actually that would be better than what
they do now because even if you see the
odds police patrol going if you're gonna
commit street crime you're probably
going to not commit it where they drive
around you know I'm not a big fan of
them just walking around I think that's
probably a bit naff but I am a big fan
of walking around machine guns like they
do in Parliament Square I mean I was
down in Parliament not long ago and I
love to sleep police with big fuck-off
machine okay somebody wants to do
anything dangerous yeah you know and I
think most people feel the same way
you know they that you feel safe mmm you
know so you know all right well we've
got time for one more question which is
always what's the one thing that we're
not talking about well IIT that we
should be I would say it's not much the
city being banned from the European
Union yeah so even though they've just
hired Lord Panik it's a trying teach
them innit I think it's Trump probably
it's the American election because you
know that's coming up later in the year
and I think he's gonna win it drive all
the left he's completely utterly mad
which would be very funny so it's the
death of again any kind of reasonable
opposition which is which is the wrong
way to run a country you know I mean
aren't my sister lives over in America
and she's a Democrat and she's
absolutely in despair
yeah about the fact that they can't seem
to find anyone who can beat this guy
knows they've gone off the deep end man
yeah they've gone so far I mean I lived
in New York for
you know nearly ten years back in the
80s until 92 and you know I don't know
what's happened to America you see these
videos on Twitter of the added c4 crowd
fighting each other and you know turning
up in balaclavas on I don't know I mean
lebas none of that when I lived there I
don't know where that's come from I
really don't and it's very disturbing I
think and I think we need to worry about
that a little bit because Trump for
another four years I'm not I think he's
doing a terrible job actually but I just
worry that he's creating this kind of
hatred and he's fueling you know more of
the same so it won't get better I think
it would get worse and on that uplifting
note thank you very much
Trump is an issue Mike thanks for coming
to not really appreciate if people want
to tune in to your show have yeah do
that well it's already is on da bee
we're also on YouTube every day mm-hmm
and you can look for the talk radio
message there we're also we do podcasts
you know it's just just type talk radio
into Google and you'll find us and if
they want to find you on Twitter
it's a tie our oMG which is not anything
to do between being Iron Mike which some
people seem to think it's an independent
republic of microwave which is the name
of the show and also mg was taken ok
enough we'll put all the links in the
video as always thanks for tuning in
this week we'll see you in a week's time
with another brilliant episode take care
see you next week guys thanks for
watching guys as always subscribe to the
YouTube channel click the bell button
next to subscribe button so you get
notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word